la descente aux enfers de loana n'en
finît par après avoir publié la semaine
dernière la vidéo de son corps tuméfié
avoir accusé son compagnon fred cauvin
de l'avoir frappé l'ex star de
téléréalité a été hospitalisée en
urgence avant d'être interné en
psychiatrie
elle a été conduite en fauteuil roulant
à moitié consciente dans un état jugé
grave
la scène décrite est effrayante une
situation dramatique que les proches de
loana justifie par la violence de fred
cauvin résultats loana a porté plainte
contre lui est aujourd'hui hospitalisé
en psychiatrie 20 ans de drames pour la
starlette de télé réalité que nous avons
tous regarder tomber sans jamais ne rien
faire encore hospitalisés loana
pourra-t-elle s'en remettre sylvie est
avec mercy sylvie ci d'être avec nous
s'il vire tes gars vous êtes une des
meilleure amie de loana très bon ami
d'ayant vous allez me dire quand vous la
connaissez depuis une quinzaine d'années
m'a quand même à oui d'accord et nous
paraît que vous étiez proche d'elle ces
derniers jours et donc vous avez vu
drame un g 1 g total et cette histoire
me plaît pas du tout en fait
pourquoi c'est une histoire qui est
reconnu marc c'est une histoire qui me
plaît pas du tout parce que on est là
pour parler de quelqu'un qui est qui et
en détresse pied malade on est là tous
parlé de son état mais et pas de l'état
de son appartement d'accord et c'est là
que je trouve ça scandaleux déplorable
et un ami ou un ex conjoint ne peut pas
publier des choses comme cela les frais
de comment je parle de fred d'accord oui
voilà d'accord alors vous allez nous ont
parlé d'un instant de gilles vous êtes
allé enquêter de votre côté sur la peur
vous avez essayé de rentrer en contact
avec tout son entourage louis et d'en
savoir un peu plus sur tout ce qui s'est
passé
d'abord pour recontextualiser les faits
vous êtes rendus devant le chai louana
endroits où ils auraient été vus nus
mardi dernier à 16h20 quand elle est
sortie de chez elle
vous nous raconter tout regarder
alors on est précisément devant le
domicile de loana dans le 8e
arrondissement à paris c'est la première
étape de cette journée folle mardi vers
16h30 loana est sortie de chez elle très
agitée presque en convulsions les
témoins était choquée elle s'est
déshabillée elle a retiré son débardeur
puis à la remise elle était par terre un
an non en fait elle était agité parce
qu'elle avait peur d'avoir perdu son
chien titi alors là nous sommes devant
le café de la mairie c'est là où loana
s'est dirigé après avoir cherché son
chien de l'autre côté de la rue elle a
traversé elle est arrivée ici à ce
moment là il y avait deux de ses amis
qui était au café
laurent amar est sorti vers et lui a dit
luan assez moellons et le dit mais j'ai
pas le temps je cherche titi t'as pas vu
thi ty elle était très agité et elle est
reparti en courant par là bas vers le
commissariat qui est situé à 100 mètres
là bas dernière étape avant l'hôpital de
cette journée incroyable dans la vie de
loana c'est ici qu'elle est entrée
directement dans ce commissariat
elle était très agité n'avaient toujours
pas retrouvé son chien kitty vu son état
les policiers ont tout de suite
dialoguer avec elles ont vu que ça
n'allait pas ils l'ont gardé dans le
commissariat ils ont préféré appeler les
pompiers
et mme est plus ressorti du commissariat
jusqu'à son évacuation avec les pompiers
vers l'hôpital bichat ça votre ok on a
rencontré des gens et non mais non
cadrée mais ça nous le raconter cette
année il a été tourné dans l'est c'est
vrai alors loana qui est dans un état
inquiétant parce que c'est vrai qu'on
aime beaucoup
l'ohada et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui la
situation nous fait peur elle en est où
gilles verdez écoutez ça va pas bien du
tout elle dans un encadrement
psychiatrique c'est ce qu'il lui faut
elle mettra des semaines à s'en remettre
l'état est quand même jugé très sérieux
franchement alors autour d'elle c'est
compliqué elle est très seul
il ya deux clans qui s'affrontent donc
elle ne sait pas qui s'en remettra les
perdu elle a de gros problèmes d'argent
les relations avec sa mère sont
extrêmement compliqué sa mère n'est pas
venu la voir et il faut le dire dans son
appartement
il y avait aussi beaucoup de produits
stupéfiants que les policiers ont trouvé
elle avait pris des médicaments sûrement
des substances illicites et donc elle
est dans un état extrêmement sérieuses
et pas leur est très inquiétant s'il
vire t vous êtes une très bonne amie de
wana elle est dans quel état aujourd'hui
loana vous l'avez eue alors oui
aujourd'hui je les ai eus au téléphone
alors comment les voilà voilà elle est
enfin un petit peu la retrouver ses
esprits
parce que pour tout vous dire elle était
plutôt très très mal j'ai eu vraiment
très peur on a tous eu très très peur
est en fait là son premier coup de fil
mais qu'elle a pu avoir le droit de
donner un coup de fil a été pour moi
donc j'ai pu discuter aujourd'hui avec
elle bien sûr vous avez peur pour elle
ou pas ou sans concession la ferme
assure mais bien sûr les sourcils à
faire ou pas qu'est-ce qu'elle mène en l
epad a dit quoi faire
elle est pas le dit quoi aujourd'hui
mais elle dit qu'elle rend plus salée
encore sous l'effet des médicaments donc
on est toujours un petit peu
mais calais 1 mais par contre il faut se
dire que quelqu'un qui est malade n'est
pas dingue
elle sait très bien ce qu haïti afin que
vous envoyez un message en expliquant je
veux crever oui tout à fait elle veut
creuser
non mais vous essayez de lui dire que
c'est c'est n'importe quoi qu'il faut
qu'elle se ressaisisse
mais bien sûr mais tous les gens mais
mais mais tous les gens qui sont cuits
polaire ou schizophrène
si c'est l'échec total de la victime de
la psychiatrie penser que c'est la télé
réalité qui l'a mise dans cet état non
non non maintenant ça n'a pas aidé on
veut dire à l'été elle est jeune elle
était fragile en entrant dans le loft
tout le monde le savait hélas mais voilà
ça n'a pas aidé évidemment que ça n'a
pas aidé c'est quelqu'un qui a une
histoire déjà à la base très compliqué
sa maman l'a abandonné petit par son
père abattu par super violée par son
père est bon et si après sa fille ça
c'est un autre sujet 1
après il ya la gloire de ce fameux loft
secret story ça sera du départ dont sera
puni dans le bon sens mais a pu profiter
cette lumière et malheureusement ça fait
l'effet inverse mais effectivement elle
sort de deux du programme
rappelez vous c'est un phénomène et elle
est aimé par tout le monde c'est vrai
qu'elle a pas pu la quadra et c'est vrai
qu'on veut bien sûr mon lait mais c'est
dommage c'est qu'elle avait arrêté j'ai
mon côté ce qui m était bien entouré oui
madame vous avez l'air un peu fataliste
sujet de loana mais nous ce qu'on
aimerait savoir c'est s'il ya quelqu'un
qu'il l'aide pour de vrai si un
programme qui est prévu qu est ce qu
elle peut se faire dans les jours qui
arrivent
et comment qu est ce qu est ce qu elle
vous dit quand vous l'avez au téléphone
ok donc non non je suis pas quelqu'un de
sata liste du tout je suis quelqu'un de
ba qui voit les choses est et du sindh
surtout voilà donc
je les ai vus très très mal au plus bas
et honnêtement j'avais peur son coeur
s'arrête un d'accord et pourquoi je suis
bien d'accord pour le savoir janka a
c'est vraiment vous n'avez pas filmer
chez loana j'espère devant ce que les
gens vont savoir où elle habite
non c'est maintenant c'est tout à côté
dans le perco loana il est inculte et
mais quand même c'est de pouvoir se
ressaisir vite espoir vite bien sûr
qu'il ya espoir il faut avoir il doit
être soigné mais alors quel genre des
douaniers rsa il faut qu'elle fasse
phone est aussi de faire une personne
c'est sa mère conclure dessus ce
pourquoi elle a été hospitalisée aussi
c'est parce que vu la quantité de
médicaments et de substances qu'il y
avait chez elle très clairement il ya
une crainte des gens qui étaient autour
d'elle et des autorités
si elle rentrait chez elle dans l'état
où elles étaient elles auraient pu
prendre beaucoup de médicaments et de
drogue et ç'aurait pu être presque
suicidaire donc on sait il ya eu une
mobilisation autour d'elle son seul
horizon
c'est en début 2021
l'anniversaire va fêter m6 du loft m6
ont escroqué alors moi je moi je suis
pas dû aimer pardonnez moi mais je suis
pas du tout une vraiment d'accord avec
vous et une mobilisation une
mobilisation à côté d'elle effectivement
en fait il ya certaines personnes qui
veut se protéger même pas s'ils
connaissent les choses se chie dessus
tout simplement pourquoi pourquoi oui
pardon sais pas de quoi ils ont les bras
parce que cette idée de déshabillage de
personnes nées phase 1 et s'installe
côté d'elle et elle d'ailleurs est le
site bien et sait très bien qui s est
tout le monde sait qui est ce qu'on peut
faire pour aider loin dangereux acolytes
les bat déjà qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
pour aider loana il faudra déjà qu elle
s aident à ne plus être amoureuse parce
que quand elle est quand même amoureuse
à corps de quelqu'un mais qui n' emprise
terrible sur elle
terrible sur elle est bon on a la
version des deux les deux peuvent être
crédibles - not pourquoi pas moi je veux
bien croire les deux d'accord mais là où
il n'est plus crédible c'est que pour
moi tout ce qui a été fait ce jour là
a été manigancé bien évidemment le mec
il est il est passé en garde à vue il a
fait 72 heures et ne parle de la zone on
va pas repartir là dessus je foutais
dans celle aux anneaux ça on va en
reparler
ce qu'on voudrait nous c est d loi ne
lui donnait des nouvelles merci en tout
cas s'il vit d'abord il n'était même pas
l'aider de voeux de faire dd des photos
de son appartement d'appeler la police
pour se protéger tout simplement je
trouve pas ça bien du tout horrible